all right good now I'll do this a bit
quicker this time just because what's
taking me time to the writing when you
think about the other case how is it
going to be different what will be
different okay we'll have a look I just
do this in another color right go back
to the first line right if there's a
minus here then that minus will come
along for the ride whenever you have an
eye do you agree with that so this one
will be a minus what are this one well
it'll be minus I squared right or you
will get the I squared and then the
minus will also get squared which will
become a difficult plus right that's
fine like this one how many negatives
will there be there will be three two of
them will cancel out leaving one yeah
and then this last one of you just go
that way i read that right do you agree
with that okay so do you see what's
happening there how are these Midas's
going to interact with these minuses
have a look thanks Eddie I don't have
this minus here where this minus come
from before it came out from pull that I
squared out did you notice that but now
I've got an extra- there so this is
going to become plus and then this one's
going to become minus right and then
everything else to be the same for the
same reason that I noticed before the
last term will still be an n-bit because
this is still true do you agree with
that okay so therefore i'm just going to
write this out having done Hall of those
lines I can say it n 0 minus from there
and 1 i minus + 2 +
Plus valu- there we go okay so you can
write these extra lines with your
alternating times just to be sure that
you will end up with this do you'll end
up with this adjuster and then yeah all
I have to do look at the result you have
to prove look at the result look
carefully at it right do you see it has
those alternating signs right the
alternative signs that we wanted right
but I'm just have a look at the series
that's their and the serious we've got
there's something that's we've got
that's missing there what's missing look
at the numbers on the bottoms of the end
whatever's yeah all of the UM all the
odd numbers are gone did you notice that
the 1 3 5 7 etc why they gone the
kids'll look see see how this guy wrong
column this guy and this guy when I add
them clearly gonna cancel right where's
the next one along it's going to be this
one which is negative and this song
which is plus and then the next one will
be the fifth one and the fifth one right
well at the end one is that going to be
an even one or an odd one it's even
because n is a multiple of oh good ok so
now i can sad these things right
therefore 1 plus i 1 minus i right
really to do this long form you should
write these whole lines you should do
the straight substitution ok but i am
going to for the sake of time to skip
over those we saw all these red things
they cancelled out but the opposite is
that you get now doubles of these yes
doubles of these every time so I've got
two of these and then I've got two of
what I got two of these that's actually
a minus isn't it yeah I two of these
and so on and then I'll have two of the
very last one hi I wasn't supposed to
get to why have I got to look there is
all you tryna proof look at the reside
you trying to prove what's on that right
hand side what's that route to with that
control I don't need her to tea we 02
frog uh-huh yeah it's good i did this
bent into waters theorem thing right i
found that this was this well this
exactly what's on the left hand side you
see it so i can just switch it for this
i can write to route to the end this
cause whatever business right that thing
ya see that equals two of these and two
of these two of these that's a heck of a
lot of two's and thankfully i can clear
out the water it just yeah yep so we are
so very close I've got ripped through to
the end here because I've cancelled this
too I've got all of these guys well I
don't need that to anymore all these
guys all the signs are right just have a
look at them actually a minus dot a dot
ok now look carefully the right-hand
side is perfect it lines up exactly the
left-hand side has this thing that's
good that's got what is that what is
that doing there what on earth is that
doing there
mmm now what I've got like they want
this then they want this and what I've
got is is this yes do you agree so how
does that tons of that remember remember
how did I am how did I do this I don't
do that how i get rid of those on either
yemm's I did it because ends not just
any number it's a multiple of four do
you notice that okay so I actually can
work out what some of these are for
example the first one the first kind of
ni can have is going to be what's the
first notable for its fall right so the
first one will be cause for pylon for
collars pie cause fire it's going to be
negative 13 good what's the next end
going to be 88 pie on four that's cause
of 2 pi to pi it goes all the way down
back up to 1 what's the next one 12 do
you need me to do we need to go through
it okay now how is this related to this
of a look a look did you see you see
this is just negative 1 to the one
negative one squared maybe one cute
right I wanted to go up and up and up
how is this related to the 4 8 12 well
this is for on for isn't it and this is
8 on for and this is 12 14 it's n on for
every time and on for every time okay so
therefore i can replace this cause
whatever thing it just goes negative 1 1
negative 1 1 we actually have fancy name
for this we call a switching factor
because it switches you back and forth
and back and forth in extension one
you'll meet it when you're doing general
solution for sewing okay so on the base
of this I actually should I just ran up
the space over there actually should
have this as my argument for why
I can replace that with that okay this
is my reason why because I can establish
the pan